c'était l'hiver avec un peu
d'imagination on pourrait presque croire
que nous sommes revenus au début du 20e
siècle à l'époque où l'on passait encore
le certificat d'études
cet après midi 19 seniors de villepreux
ont planché sur les épreuves de ce
diplôme emblématique supprimé il ya 30
ans c'est pas si simple
c'est pas si simple de se remettre à se
remettre dans le bain après la dictée
place à la rédaction ou encore aux
calculs avant une pause goûter comme au
début du siècle dernier un retour en
arrière fortement apprécié par les
participants
ben ça me rappelle que je pensais
matière de dégâts des dieux dans 1950
je leur passe à nouveau nous ça me
rappelle les bons vielles dictée
questions calcul qu'on faisait dans ce
temps là et qui nous ont donné un très
bon orthographe une très belle calcul
mental que non plus tous les enfants une
opération proposée par la mairie de
villepreux qui avait notamment pour
souhait de créer du lien social
c'est leur permettra de passer un
agréable après-midi et de tisser du lien
et que nous puissions aussi tisser du
lien avec eux et qu'ils puissent aussi
tisser du lien entre eux parce qu'ils
n'ont pas tous toujours à l'occasion
de se rencontrer des élèves studieux
puisqu'ils ont tous obtenu le fameux
diplôme du certificat d'études primaires